la fibrilación auricular es un tipo de
arritmia la cual implica una anormalidad
en el ritmo o en la fuerza de los
latidos del corazón si usted padece de
fibrilación auricular las cámaras
superiores del corazón se contraerán de
una manera rápida y desordenada
provocando un latido cardíaco
descoordinado e irregular el corazón es
un órgano muscular que se compone de
cuatro cámaras las aurículas izquierda y
derecha y los ventrículos izquierdo y
derecho
durante un latido cardíaco normal las
cámaras de su corazón se contraen y se
relajan en un patrón rítmico para
ofrecer un flujo constante de sangre por
todo su cuerpo
la aurícula derecha recibe la sangre del
cuerpo
y el ventrículo derecho la bombea hacia
los pulmones los cuales llevan oxígeno y
eliminan el dióxido de carbono de la
sangre
al mismo tiempo la aurícula izquierda
recibe la sangre de los pulmones
y el ventrículo izquierdo la bombea para
suministrar oxígeno y nutrientes a los
tejidos del cuerpo
cada latido del corazón empieza en el
marcapasos natural del corazón llamado
nódulo sinusal o nódulo s/a ubicado en
la pared de la aurícula derecha aquí se
inicia una señal eléctrica luego se
propaga a través de ambas aurículas
provocando que se contraigan y expulsa
en la sangre hacia los ventrículos
a medida que las aurículas se relajan la
señal viaja a través del nódulo atrio
ventricular o nódulo
ave hacia las paredes ventriculares
haciendo que se contraigan los
ventrículos se relajan consiguiendo un
latido completo
inmediatamente el nódulo s/a genera un
nuevo impulso eléctrico repitiendo el
patrón
en la fibrilación auricular las señales
eléctricas se originan en lugares
inusuales en las aurículas y cerca de
las venas pulmonares
estas señales anormales viajan a través
de las aurículas al azar provocando que
las aurículas se contraigan de manera
rápida y desordenada
las señales bombardean al nódulo ave
provocan que los ventrículos se
contraigan rápidamente incluso en un
ritmo aún más rápido las contracciones
ventriculares no pueden mantener el
ritmo de las rápidas contracciones
auricular es lo que provoca un latido
del corazón descoordinado después de
estas contracciones irregulares es
posible que las cámaras no se vacíen por
completo cuando la sangre se acumula en
las aurículas podría formarse coágulos
un coágulo puede desprenderse del
corazón y viajar a través de su cuello
hacia su cerebro
causando un derrame cerebral
la acumulación de sangre en los
ventrículos impide que el oxígeno y los
nutrientes lleguen a los tejidos del
cuerpo si constantemente su corazón no
puede bombardear la sangre suficiente
para satisfacer las necesidades de su
cuerpo entonces usted puede desarrollar
una insuficiencia cardíaca
su médico puede tratar su fibrilación
auricular con medicamentos
antiarrítmicos los medicamentos
antiarrítmicos controlan las señales
eléctricas enviadas a sus aurículas que
ayudan a que su corazón lata a un ritmo
regular después del tratamiento es
posible que su corazón todavía lata muy
rápido en este caso su médico podría
darle medicamentos beta bloqueadores
para que su frecuencia cardíaca
disminuya y sea normal
además el médico puede recomendar
procedimientos que restauren el ritmo y
la frecuencia normal del corazón tales
como la cardioversión
la ablación
o colocación de marcapasos
en la cardioversión eléctrica su médico
administrará una descarga a su corazón a
fin de iniciar un ritmo cardíaco normal
durante la ablación
el cirujano utilizará energía de
radiofrecuencia para destruir el tejido
cardíaco que genera las señales
eléctricas anormales
en la colocación de marcapasos el
cirujano implantará un pequeño
dispositivo debajo de la piel cerca de
su corazón para regular su ritmo
cardíaco